the court is unanimous in accepting that
the Assurance is given by the Rwandan
government were made in good faith and
were intended to address any defects in
the Asylum process
however the majority believes that the
evidence does not establish that the
necessary changes have by then been
reliably affected
or would have been at the time of the
proposed removals
in consequence sending anyone to Rwanda
would constitute a breach of article 3
of the European convention on human
rights which Parliament has required the
government to comply with
in agreement with the high court I have
reached the opposite conclusion
I agree that the procedures put in place
under the Rwandan agreement and the
assurances given by the Rwandan
government are sufficient to ensure that
there is no real risk that Asylum
Seekers relocated under the Rwanda
policy will be wrongly returned to
countries where they face persecution or
other inhumane treatment
I have concluded that the chances of
failed Asylum Seekers being returned to
their countries of origin are in any
event low not least because Rwanda has
no agreements in place with any of the
countries in question
in addition extensive monitoring
Arrangements formal and informal of all
those sent to Rwanda and of their Asylum
claims once there provide powerful
protection